you supported president obama and you
were in a private meeting with him
how [ __ ] weird is that wait where did
you read that i know here's the thing
i did have a meeting with i got to meet
him for like three minutes
now hold it when you say you got to meet
him you went to a private room and met
him right
like in a hotel i was waiting in a
like almost like a hallway that he was
walking through
and would like meet me on the way to
another thing it wasn't like
immediate you know it was like it was
arranged it wasn't a big
it was it was arranged because you
supported him and did a video for him
during the campaign was that the right
maybe maybe but you know i think the
white house doesn't want people
to be able to use fodder like oh he's
meeting with celebrities meanwhile i'm
not a celebrity i made a video for it
you know what i mean i don't think it's
so bad that he gave me two minutes of
his time while he went to say thank you
so what was the meeting anyway i mean
okay i mean it wasn't
me but it was really like it was just me
uh
my agent michael kevis who does a lot of
work at the white house he's like a
political guy or he's the guy who sends
them movies and stuff when they want
movies
and uh he walks through and
just know that i know it's very nice
what he said but i know that there was
somebody right before he walked through
he's like she's a comedian she's around
about she made a video you know i mean
it's not like i think yeah i think he
comes in yeah he shakes my hand he goes
oh i'm a big fan you're very you're very
talented though i
turn the volume down when my girls come
into the room
thank you and then um but i was so
nervous and excited like it's so funny
because before i went in there i was
like
what should i bring up i emailed my like
uh brother-in-law who's like in israel
and a real political guy he's like
ask him about darfur and this and number
one i'm like yeah yeah
but then of course you get there and
you're just like hi
[Laughter]
he goes uh kevis is talking about them
you know
how he likes foreign films and it's very
impressive he goes yeah i don't like the
bloody stuff i don't like the scary
stuff and i go
and all of a sudden i feel my mouth
moving and i'm like me either i don't
even like pixar movies that
they i the thought of a lonely robot in
space kills me
you know and then he's like well i'll
have to disagree with you on the pixar
front and i'm like huh
and then he goes what do you have coming
up and then i go
i'm gonna be naked in a movie
i'm so embarrassed i had no control over
my mouth i don't know
here you are so accomplished you speak
for a living you're so well thought out
and calculated in that sense and there
you got in front of the president and
you really kind of [ __ ] choked right
yeah i i didn't choke but i got i got
diarrhea of the mouth and and was
really tired but you're right like
you're totally starchy yeah
so beautiful yeah handsome huh oh my god
he gave me a hug his body is like it's
like a thorough breath
like pure just muscle and that is
amazing story
because you know what you're right you
want to bring up something intellectual
but in a three-minute drive by you can't
uh
bring up something intellectual before
you meet the president does the secret
service sit there and frisk you
or or do some sort of background check
no nothing
he could have been a terrorist they
don't even know it could have been [ __ ]
is michelle with him or the kids with
it's just you no i mean i think he was
there on business going from one meeting
to another and they
enabled this kind of like if you're in
the hallway between one
place and another you know you can so it
was just for you it wasn't like a lineup
of people it was you and
thank god he was able to have something
of a normal conversation
and break up your awkward conversation
well this is what happened too is
at this point in my life you know my
show was over
and i decided i'm not gonna feel bad
about not knowing what i'm doing next
my job now is to daydream you know so i
was like literally at home
totally unwashed and gross sitting in a
chair like
this and the phone rings and it's
it's kivis who like a lot of times the
things he wants me to do
are not good you know anything
interesting or what i want to do it's
more like a favor for someone else that
involves me
so i go hello and he goes where are you
right now he goes what are you doing
right now and i go
writing and he goes where did i go
my apartment and then he's like i think
i could be the president and i go oh my
god
i have to wash my hair so then i go i
wash my hair
and then i get out of the shower and it
says oh it looks like it might not
happen and i'm thinking
is this some sort of trick to get me to
wash my hair because
can honestly see that that is you know
so uh but then it
ended up working out yeah beautiful hair
i gotta say thank you but i don't wash
it too much it's dry you know
it's very nice but that is kind of crazy
because you
want so to have make a connection yeah
you say something you know
what are you doing about darfur you know
this is a genocide instead i'm like goes
naked
naked i know she did well i had just
come back from it but still it was just
like
gross